[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit niki
sehr guten abend mit mir im studio für
den sport dass wieder norbert lehmann
guten abend auch von mir der krieg in
der ukraine wütet weiter die wichtigsten
geschehnisse haben wir auch heute für
sie im blick
hier steht weiter unter beschuss in
manchen teilen ist die lage
lebensgefährlich trotzdem sind drei
osteuropäische eu regierungschefs zu
gesprächen in die stadt gereist
3 millionen menschen sind mittlerweile
aus der ukraine geflüchtet unter anderem
in die republik moldau eines der ärmsten
länder der region
und wissenschaftler schlagen alarm
während der korona krise hat sich die
lesekompetenz bei viertklässlern
deutlich verschlechtert
nach 20 tagen krieg verhandeln beide
seiten zwar wieder aber der
bemerkenswerteste schritt auf
diplomatischer ebene ist sicherlich dass
die regierungschefs von polen tschechien
und slowenien ins hartumkämpfte kiew
gereist sind ziemlich riskant wie
dramatisch und gefährlich es in der
ukrainischen hauptstadt nämlich ist
zeigt der bericht von luton linus und
lena sünder bruch in der nacht und am
frühen morgen war die ukrainische
hauptstadt das ziel schwere luftangriffe
mehrere wohnblocks wurden getroffen
mindestens vier menschen sollen getötet
worden sein
bürgermeister klitschko verkündete eine
sofortige zwei tage lange ausgangssperre
über kiew er sprach von einem
gefährlichen moment für die stadt
ich appelliere an alle männer die ihre
familien in sicherheit gebracht haben
nun wieder nach kiew zurück zu kommen
wir müssen unsere stadt und unsere
zukunft verteidigen
inzwischen sind die regierungschefs von
polen tschechien und slowenien
wohlbehalten mit ihren zug in kiew
eingetroffen
und 1,5 millionen einwohner haben die
hauptstadt seit kriegsausbruch verlassen
die flucht ist oft lebensgefährlich das
zeigen diese bilder in der ukrainischen
überwachungsdrohne sie wurden der zdf
redaktion frontal zugespielt entstanden
sind sie westlich von kiew an einer
russischen panzer stellung zu sehen ist
nach angaben ukrainischer militärs die
erschießung eines zivilisten offenbar
durch russische soldaten
auch am tag 20 dieses krieges stehen
ukrainische städte im fokus der
russischen offensive zum nordosten harke
und optiker
in der nacht erneut gewaltige
explosionen in der millionenstadt
kharkiv die luftangriffe gingen auch
tagsüber während der rettungsarbeiten
weiter
die spektakuläre protestaktion einer
journalistin während der
hauptnachrichten des russischen
fernsehens hatte heute ein nachspiel sie
hatte auf einem plakat nein zum krieg
gefordert und sich von falsch
nachrichten distanziert
ich schäme mich sehr dafür dass ich
zugelassen habe dass solche lügen aus
dem fernsehen kommen da sich die
gehirnwäsche des russischen volkes
zugelassen habe ein moskauer gericht
verurteilte sie am abend zu einer
geldstrafe setzte sie vorerst aber auf
freien fuß
und wir sind jetzt verbunden mit katrin
eigendorf im südukrainischen odessa und
anne gellinek in brüssel zunächst du dir
alle drei osteuropäische eu
regierungschefs auf gefährlicher mission
in kiew was soll das
vordergründig haben die drei
premierminister diese reise letzte woche
auf dem gipfel in versailles angekündigt
und abgesprochen sie haben gleichwohl
keinen offiziellen auftrag der eu dafür
bekommen und dass sie heute ausgerechnet
in dieser situation dieses husarenstück
wagen hat die spitzen hier in brüssel
doch kalt erwischt eu kommission und eu
gipfelchef beeilten sich zwar heute zu
versichern dass sie jede unterstützung
der ukraine begrüßen würden aber hinter
den kulissen gibt es doch erhebliche
sorgen zum beispiel darüber welche
fragen man sich hier in europa stellen
müsste wenn einem drei europäischen
premierminister etwas zustoßen würde
wenn er von einer russischen rakete
getroffen würde außerdem gibt es zweifel
dass die drei osteuropäer alle glühende
unterstützer der ukraine tatsächlich die
offizielle eu linie vertreten und nicht
auf eigene rechnung arbeiten also
öffentlich vorsichtige unterstützung für
den trip aber laut sagen tut keiner dass
man sich nicht sicher ist ob diese reise
diese hochgehaltene einheit der eu er
gefährdet oder befördert dann weiter
jetzt nach odessa zu katrin eigendorf
karten also eine höchst riskante trip
dreier eu regierungschefs wie kommt so
was in der ukraine an
die ukraine haben natürlich schon
verstanden dass ein schneller beitritt
in die europäische union für sie keine
wirkliche perspektive ist das hat man
ihnen ja jetzt deutlich immer wieder
klar gemacht und die leute mit denen ich
heute hier über diesen besuch geredet
habe die haben mir gesagt ja es ist
eigentlich jetzt genug der gesten wir
erwarten hier mal konkrete handlungen
und sie sehen sich ja selber als
europäer und sagen ihr müsst jetzt auch
mal dem rechnung tragen dass wir
europäer sind und im prinzip uns gegen
russland stellen das ist die stimmung
hier man muss das auch natürlich damit
erklären dass die menschen hier unter
wachsenden druck geraten denn auch
odessa das hören wir aus ukrainischen
militärkreisen könnte möglicherweise die
nächste stadt sein die jetzt hier von
russischer seite angegriffen wird wie
wir hören sind russische panzer nur noch
50 kilometer von der stadt entfernt
auch kriegsschiffe haben hier positionen
bezogen manche ukrainische militärs
gehen davon aus dass in den frühen
morgenstunden oder dieser nacht hier
eine großoffensive erfolgen könnte dann
dankeschön nach odessa katrin eigendorf
auch dank nach brüssel zu anne gellinek
ja womit deshalb noch rechnet das
passiert schon längst in der hauptstadt
kiew tod unendliches leid massenflucht
und zerstörung dieser krieg wird immer
brutaler und der trifft immer häufiger
auch zivilisten die daran verzweifeln
wir uns jetzt der freie journalist arndt
ginzel zeigt
amprion eine wohnsiedlung fünf kilometer
vom stadtzentrum entfernt um 5
explodiert eine rakete brennende
wohnungen manche werden um bewohner
bleiben die ganze front des
zehnstöckigen wohnhauses zerstört
verzweiflung bei den bewohnern
sind selbst flüchtlinge mein vater ist
invalide ich war mit meinem mann drinnen
wir konnten ihn rausziehen und haben
gott sei dank alle überlebt aber wir
wissen nicht wie es weitergehen soll
wohin mit vater man den zwei kindern das
kleine ist doch als breit
und entsteht das auto von irina darin
eine alte behinderte frau es ist ihre
90-jährige mutter seit der attacke am
morgen liegt sie auf dem rücksitz irina
ist außer sich
das sind keine menschen in syrien haben
sie alles bombardiert und die welt hat
geschwiegen nur geschrieben die halbe
ukraine haben sie sich benommen 2014 die
ganze welt schweigt
sie nimmt uns mit hoch in ihre wohnung
überall scherben die fensterscheiben
zerborsten löcher in der balkonbrüstung
nachts hat es - gerade
sogar ein küchen tablett aus metall
durchschlagen
das hier war das schlafzimmer ihrer
mutter die nun hier erstmal nicht mehr
schlafen kann ehring us schwester
90 jahre ist sie alt invalide jetzt
sitzt sie im auto sie braucht ein
spezielles bett seit ihrem schlaganfall
wohin sollen wir jetzt mit ihr
es ist vor allem die ukrainische
bevölkerung die immer mehr leidet
dieses wohnviertel liegt nicht in einem
gebiet in dem militärische objekte
existieren es ist also auch ein krieg
gegen die zivilbevölkerung der hier
geführt wird auch anderswo in kiew
einschläge in dieser apotheke werden
erstmal keine medikamente mehr verkauft
werden können
mehr zur situation in und um kiew in
einem frontal- spezial um 21 uhr 15
außerdem direkt nach uns erneut ein zdf
spezial zum krieg in der ukraine und in
unserer app haben wir weitere
hintergründe unter anderem was zu der
protestaktion im russischen fernsehen
unter demonstranten bislang bekannt ist
seit kriegsbeginn sind schon rund drei
millionen menschen aus der ukraine
geflohen etwa die hälfte davon sind
kinder sagen zahlen der vereinten
nationen die meisten menschen suchen
schutz in polen 1,8 millionen schaffte
es dorthin aber auch in die republik
moldau moldawien genannt kommen
flüchtende bislang mehr als
330.000 mit einer fläche wie der von
nordrhein westfalen ist das land
vergleichsweise klein und sehr arm aber
die hilfsbereitschaft riesengroß barbara
lueg
was hier ausgerollt wird verspricht ein
bisschen glück larissa und ihre tochter
anna bereiten das essen vor für sich und
zwei familien die vor acht tagen
gemeinsam vor dem krieg aus odessa
flohen und bei ihnen unterschlupf und
wärme
es gibt so viele flüchtlinge in
moldawien die jetzt mit uns allen leben
aber wenn hier auch der krieg beginnt wo
sollen wir wollen wissen durch um 900
larissa und ihre tochter leben in kost
es die eine knappe stunde von moldawiens
hauptstadt entfernt larissa ist köchin
anna erzieherin wie so viele in europas
ärmsten land haben sie von allem wenig
aber dass wenigstens wollen sie teilen
denn der krieg treibt hier alle um
jeden tag denken wir darüber nach
moldawien zu verlassen wir wissen ja
nicht was morgen ist das risiko ist groß
denn als nachbarland ist moldawien ganz
dicht dran an diesem krieg und mit dem
ganzen grauen dort wächst auch hier die
angst der menschen dass sie die nächsten
sein könnten
wir hätten ja noch nicht mal waffen wenn
es zum krieg käme und unsere männer
arbeiten alle im ausland
sowie larissa und anna fühlen die
meisten in moldawien und suchen in
diesem chaos so kostbare momente wie
diese
plätze ist übrigens ein nationalgericht
moldawiens und an diesem tag so viel
mehr
ja jede menge menschen brauchen jede
menge hilfe wenn sie spenden möchten so
wäre es möglich beim aktionsbündnis
katastrophenhilfe
bahn.de 65 104 106 100 104 106 100
stichwort zdf nothilfe ukraine und alle
infos dazu auch auf spenden zdf.de oder
auf der zdf textseite 890
seit dem russischen angriff auf die
ukraine hinterfragt man auch wieder die
verteidigungsfähigkeit der bundeswehr
die wehrbeauftragte des bundestages eva
högl drückt es heute so aus sie sei
entsetzt über die ausrüstungsmängel die
bundeswehr müsse sich jetzt auf ihre
wichtigste aufgabe konzentrieren und fit
gemacht werden für die
landesverteidigung
heute stellte sie ihren jahresbericht
vor über den jetzt ines trams informiert
im jahr 2021 habe die bundeswehr gezeigt
was sie kann im hochwasser menschen
gerettet in gesundheitsämtern und
testzentren corona impfungen gesetzt
damit soll es nun vorbei sein die
vorstellung des berichts der
wehrbeauftragten sie steht ganz im
zeichen der zeitenwende diese amtshilfe
muss jetzt enden wir haben jetzt gerade
vor dem hintergrund des krieges in der
ukraine in der bundeswehr andere
aufgaben die kräfte müssen parat stehen
und für die amtshilfe in der korona
bekämpfung sind jetzt zivile gefragt der
bericht eine zusammenstellung von
mängeln es fehlt an helmen genauso wie
an funktionierenden großgerät mängel die
angesichts des ukraine krieges in neuem
licht erscheinen die in aussicht
gestellten 100 milliarden euro
sondervermögen kommen da gerade recht
mit diesem geld soll die volle
einsatzbereitschaft wieder hergestellt
werden mit diesem geld kann finanziert
werden was in der truppe dringend
benötigt wird und als wehrbeauftragte
sage ich ganz deutlich die priorität
muss zunächst mal darauf liegen die
ausstattung der soldatinnen und soldaten
zu verbessern die ampel parteien stehen
hinter den neuen mitteln für die
bundeswehr wie auch union und fdp
linkspartei allerdings ruft stopp keine
rüstungsspirale und keine milliarden
bevor nicht der beschaffungsprozess
reformiert ist was wir brauchen und das
fordern wir auch ist erst mal eine
vernünftige kostenanalyse wohin letzten
jahren das geld eigentlich geflossen ist
und was jetzt konkret anders werden soll
damit es nicht weiter versichert
2021 nennt die wehrbeauftragte das ja
der bundeswehr und sie ahnt auch dieses
jahr wird sicher eines in dem truppe und
politik sich mehrere nie beweisen müssen
bundesinnenministerium phaser hat den
hut in berlin pardon einen aktionsplan
gegen rechtsextremismus vorgestellt
faeser sagte von rechts käme die größte
extremistische bedrohung für die
demokratie in deutschland
der zehn punkte plan sieht unter anderem
vor rechte netzwerke zu zerschlagen
extremisten den waffenschein zu
entziehen und für die prävention die
politische bildung zu stärken
jetzt zu corona und den maßnahmen
dagegen eigentlich sollten fast alle zur
kommenden woche auslaufen aber viele
bundesländer wollen die masten pflicht
den innenräumen verlängern und zeigen
auf die infektionszahlen die heute
wieder gestiegen sind binnen 24 stunden
wurden dem rk ii
198 1888 neue fälle gemeldet
42.000 89 mehr als vor einer woche
283 menschen starben an oder mit dem
virus die sieben tage incidents liegt
jetzt bei
1585 und damit so hoch wie noch nie
von anfang an haben die korona maßnahmen
auch besonders schülerinnen und schüler
getroffen mit ziemlich heftigen folgen
wie eine studie jetzt bestätigt demnach
ist die lesekompetenz bei 4 class land
deutlich gesunken vor allem bei den
ohnehin schon benachteiligten verfügten
vor fünf jahren 22 prozent nur über eine
schwache oder sehr schwache
lesefähigkeit sind es jetzt 28 prozent
und das wirkt sich in fast jedem fach
aus dazu dort ferber
[Musik]
so flüssig wie romy lesen längst nicht
alle diese düsseldorfer zweitklässler
kennen schule nur in pandemie zeiten das
hat folgen für ihre lesefähigkeit sagt
die lehrerin
die sind einfach schwächer die können
auch nicht kleine texte erfassen wir
sind jetzt noch bei setzen und ich würde
sagen im vergleich zu anderen vorgängen
war zu diesem zeitpunkt was im zweiten
halbjahr des schuljahres reich weiter
das gefühl trügt nicht bei
viertklässlern fehlt laut einer
repräsentativen studie durchschnittlich
ein halbes schuljahr an lesefähigkeit
und im vergleich zu 2016 ist die zahl
der schwachen leser von 22 auf 28
prozent gestiegen die der starken leser
von 44 auf 37 prozent gesunken
wir können aber auch beobachten dass
bestimmte gruppen besonders betroffen
sind das betrifft zum einen kinder die
ihr ungünstigere lernbedingungen zu
hause haben also zum beispiel keinen
eigenen schreibtisch keine eigenen
internetanschluss in der familie oder
auch kinder mit migrationshintergrund
sinnerfassend lesen fällt immer mehr
kindern schwer ein alarmierender befund
und es mangelt an lehrkräften
wir brauchen mehr personal weil wir
überall auf kante genäht sind damit die
individuelle förderung überhaupt möglich
ist das heißt wir brauchen die
unterstützung wir brauchen auch nicht
nur kurzfristige maßnahmen sondern wir
brauchen nachhaltige maßnahmen
lehrerinnen erzieher ehrenamtliche die
schulen brauchen nun jede unterstützung
sie wissen ohne chips geht kaum noch was
sie stecken in handys in computern autos
der us halbleiterhersteller intel geht
voll auf expansionskurs und investiert
jetzt auch milliarden in magdeburg nach
tesla zieht damit den nächsten us riesen
nach ostdeutschland zunächst fließen 17
milliarden in zwei fabriken ab 2027 soll
produziert werden 3000 neue
arbeitsplätze entstehen luisa houben und
hagen nicolas über eine mega investition
in sachsen anhalt noch liegt der acker
an der a 14 bei magdeburg brach doch ab
nächstem jahr will intel hier europas
größte chip fabrik bauen das kündigte
intel chef patrick gelsinger heute an
investitionen in höhe von 17 milliarden
euro für die errichtung von zwei
einzigartigen halbleiter fabriken in
deutschland mittel und langfristig seien
weitere fünf fabriken geplant dauerhaft
sollen so 3000 arbeitsplätze entstehen
magdeburg erhielt den zuschlag weil es
ausreichend freie fläche bot eine gute
verkehrsanbindung und ein umfeld aus
universität und forschungseinrichtungen
in magdeburg und sachsen anhalt sind die
erwartungen groß wir schaffen den rahmen
und das sich inter sozusagen für
deutschland und für sachsen-anhalt
entschieden hat ist für uns eine
botschaft die für uns noch nicht mal
fassbar ist aber in ihrer dimension
durchaus schon absehbar sind alle
voraussetzungen gegeben plant intel in
fünf jahren mit der produktion in
magdeburg zu beginnen
auch heute hat an vielen deutschen
flughäfen wieder das personal an den
sicherheitskontrollen gestreikt hunderte
flüge fielen aus wie hier am größten
deutschen flughafen in frankfurt
andere flüge gingen nur mit passagieren
aus dem transitbereich
die gewerkschaft verdi fordert
mindestens einen euro mehr pro stunde
morgen steht die nächste
verhandlungsrunde
so wir schauen jetzt auf die
fußball-bundesliga norbert und zum
nachholspiel mainz gegen dort ja unter
könnte der bvb den titelkampf neu
entfachen ein sieg gegen die nullfünfer
ja und die schwarz-gelben hätten nur
noch vier punkte abstand auf
tabellenführer münchen dortmund ohne
kapitän reus aber wieder mit stürmerstar
ellinghorst
macht er morgen wieder den unterschied
erling hollern nach zuletzt 30 minütigen
comeback ist gegen mainz mehr
einsatzzeit möglich und eventuell nötig
um zu gewinnen dann stehen drei punkte
mehr auf unserem konto der abstand zu
bayern wird wird enger und alle freuen
sich über möglicherweise eine spannende
endphase aber wer wird für mainz nach
kona zwangspause überhaupt auf dem platz
stehen es wird halt nicht 10 23 spieler
bei uns sein also wenn schon beim
größten teil
spieler von von der erste mannschaft
dabei morgen haben aber da ist der bvb
derzeit vielleicht besser aufgestellt
und jetzt zu manual superstar cristiano
ronaldo sein team spielt am abend im
champions league achtelfinal rückspiel
gegen atletico madrid nach dem 1 1 im
hinspiel muss manchester united gewinnen
ronaldo jedenfalls hat sich am samstag
schon mal warm geschossen ist das noch
manchester united oder doch eher der fc
ronaldo diese frage stellt sich nachdem
drei toren des 73 sich jährigen
portugiesen am wochenende gegen
tottenham ganz nebenbei die treffer 805
bis 807 seiner langen karriere
weltrekord zumindest nach zählweise der
fifa trotz dieser ghana das verhältnis
zu trainer ralf rangnick bleibt
vorsichtig formuliert geschäftsmäßig es
dadurch nur cristiano sondern um das
ganze team nach der ersten halbzeit im
hinspiel stand es nur 1 0 für die
bekannt unbequemen spanier atlético
hatte ein klares plus an chancen dass
eins zu eins keine garantie fürs
weiterkommen many hofft auf einen
weiteren glanztat von ronaldo und die
achtelfinal rückspiele morgen abend bei
uns ausführlich zu sehen in sportstudio
champions league ab 23 vielen dank an
norbert und wir hätten noch ein
naturschauspiel im angebot das es in
deutschland tatsächlich nur ganz selten
zu sehen gibt polarlichter haben den
himmel erleuchtet hier bilder sie werden
es nicht glauben aus brandenburg so
etwas entsteht nach eruptionen auf der
sonne wenn ein so genannter sonnenwind
das magnetfeld der erde trifft und dann
luftpartikel zum leuchten bringt und es
gab noch was besonderes heute
saharastaub bei uns mehr erklärt
gleicher stelle marietta slomka bringt
sie auf den stand der dinge um 22 uhr im
heute-journal von uns im heute 19 team
war es das schönen dank einen schönen
abend und bis morgen
[Musik]
schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter es lag heute was
in der luft und zwar saharastaub und
durch aus dem süden deutschlands war das
zu sehen und auch in frankreich bis
weiter nach spanien
und so wird es auch morgen wieder
saharastaub geben und das könnte die
temperaturen etwas dämpfen wir schauen
erst in die nacht und dieser regnier der
zieht allmählich aber es bildet sich
teilweise nebel und die temperaturen
sinken auf minus zwei grad im hessischen
bergland und plus sieben grad im
südosten deutschlands morgen erst einmal
viele wollten dann lockert es von westen
her auf die sonne kommt mehr und mehr
vor aber der sahara staub kann durchaus
uns ein strich durch die rechnung machen
und dann bleibt der himmel durchaus auch
trüb die temperaturen dazu maximalwerte
von 7 grad an der ostsee häufig
zweistellig 14 15 nach westen bei 17
grad und 19 grad am oberrhein die
nächsten tage am donnerstag gibt es
etwas regen er durchzieht einmal nach
osten bei temperaturen bis 18 grad
freitag und samstag sind dann sehr
trocken und es wird immer sonniger damit
wünsche ich ihnen ein schöner abend